[Music]
all right let's take one more call let's
go to
tony in los angeles california
i don't even know what that accent was i
think that accident was my pirate accent
i don't know man sorry tony it's all
good this show's getting off the rails
today brother
no thank you man what's up i just wanna
hey i just wanna also shout out your
team uh you guys have an awesome team
over there
totally disagree totally disagree yeah
well
and i also want to shout out team fender
just so i have the chance to
my man
hey tony the signal's bad we can't hear
you anymore
so yeah the reason for my call um just
to get straight
down to it is i got a buddy who's
struggling with alcoholism
okay hiding it from his wife denying it
when we kind of asked him about it um
mainly come into bible studies that we
host on weekends he's come
at least one time last week definitely
under the influence and then
notice that he's came to other like
softball games kind of influence but
it's totally just no i'm fine knows he's
struggled with it in the past
but he just doesn't want to basically
admit that he's been
under the influence and then recently
we've had to
um deny some of our friends with driving
with him because we're just not sure
hey is he going to be you know capable
of driving and
some of our family friends who have kids
because he has a you know granddaughters
and
we're like hey we just want to let you
guys know this is a situation
and i i called him the days after just
to kind of say
you know love on them and say hey man
you know i just want to make sure
everything's okay
you know what's going on is there
something we can come alongside you
and he's just like no everything's great
um you know pie in the sky my marriage
is doing great
which you know unfortunately we know
that it is a little rocky obviously
because of the situation
we just want to know the right steps we
don't want to come out attacking we just
want to be able to love on him and
bridge those gaps
like as a community just to kind of walk
alongside him with this
well i appreciate your heart brother and
um
i appreciate you wanting to do this
right and these are messy
friendships are hard especially when
your friends are hurting
um how long have you been in a
relationship with this dude how long
have you all been buddies
so we've known each other for more than
probably five to
five six years okay is his wife part of
the gang too
she is yeah so we're all kind of we have
a really tight
family um family group community
um we some of us go to separate churches
but we do try to meet once a week
um for our study and then also once a
month through
a park day with all their kids and our
families and we just try to have that
community aspect for getting out there
doing things and
so we're in we're in each other's lives
a lot um
some some of us more than others because
some of us you know are the age gap is
different you know me and my wife in our
30s
this mike and his wife are in their late
50s but we're all kind of still
living life together so this is a a dude
who's almost 60 years old who's
struggling
yeah okay yeah so this is going to be
hard because he looks at you like his
kid
right and he looks at you like a little
whippersnapper that he's helping through
life
right um
man and he's he's come to me and the
guys before telling us that he had a
struggle with this and it was it was
pretty vague it was probably a few
months ago he's like
yeah you know i struggle with drinking
you know i me and my wife
kind of know that we need to step back
on it a little bit i feel like i have to
hide it but then sometimes we go out
and have drinks together so it was we
never really got like a clear cut answer
if he was looking for sobriety or if he
was just trying to
not drink as much and we just never
really got a clear definition even i
asked some of the guys and they didn't
really understand what
that kind of meeting was about either
what he was trying to ask of us yeah so
i'm gonna answer this dude
this isn't always the right answer in
this situation
addiction is really tricky i'm gonna
answer this
as though he was my friend okay
and i have a reputation with my friends
that i will lean directly into hard
conversations
okay and um i've got friends who do the
same thing for me
i've got friends for that are years and
years whether it's craig or trevor or
john or
guys that i've known for years and they
will say
hey i remember my buddy kevin said
i made a joke about my wife this is 10
years ago and he said hey
just for the record never again
right and he's still a close buddy right
so that's the kind of community i run
with
and so a guy like this you've been
friends with for five or six years
this is a guy that i'm gonna take out
and i'm gonna take him with a couple of
us
and we're gonna tell him hey um we're
not asking anymore we know that you're
struggling
and we're here to be a part of this
solution we're here to help any way that
we can
um but we're not gonna let you put
people in harm's way anymore and we're
gonna ask you
if you're drunk don't come don't come to
church
right don't come out to the softball
fields if you're drunk we really want
you here
um and here's the thing you and your
buddies are gonna have to know tony this
is bigger than you
this isn't something that y'all can
solve and fix and so
he needs to go to meetings and he needs
to make a decision that he's going to go
get well
so this is a matter of y'all walking
alongside him calling it out shining a
light on this thing
and then saying we'll be here to walk
with you brother but also here are our
boundaries for being safe
i would never cut a friend out of my
life unless it got to the point that
they were unsafe you know they were
being off color or they were being
ugly and you know what i mean um but i
will draw boundaries around certain
things
so there are some friends in my life who
i love more than life itself
but i don't have them around my kids not
because i'm gonna think they're gonna
abuse everything but they just
they just they run their mouth and they
talk trash around i don't want to run my
kids
and i love them dude they're hilarious
they're fun and they actually know
i will tell them hey if you're going to
keep talking like that dude i'm not
going to draw my kids
and they say i know man sorry dude i'm
not going to change it and that's cool
we're still friends
but here's my boundary does that make
sense yeah absolutely
and if i've got a buddy who's in
recovery if i got a buddy who's
struggling with alcohol
after the game i'm gonna be again this
is how i handle these things
i'm not gonna order a beer i'm gonna be
a person of hospitality
i'm gonna make sure that that guy has at
least one person at the table not
drinking
and if he does order a beer i'm gonna
say
don't do that man not tonight and i do
that and if i know a buddy is really
working out hard on his nutrition
and i see him i'll say not today man and
just keep walking and they'll go i know
i know
and i do that because i've got people in
my life who do it for me
and it's just a way of uh if somebody
doesn't invite me to that though i don't
walk up to
some rando in the cafeteria here at
ramsey and i'm like oh wow
rice krispie treat huh i don't do that
man they didn't invite me into that
conversation
but it sounds like this cat has invited
you in he is a
part of your life relationally and
otherwise
and so as far as i'm concerned you have
an obligation to tell the truth
and you do it with the idea towards
um helping them be well and you can only
be well in relationship
right right and so that that's how i'm
handling that dude we're all going to
lunch one night or we're all going to
get breakfast one day
and nobody orders well some people order
drinks at breakfast james yeah some
people order drinks for breakfast but
go get breakfast and then you'll have
that conversation say hey we're worried
about you we know
this is a thing in our group we don't
lie to our wives
we just don't we don't hide crap from
each other we tell the truth
clearly you're struggling with alcohol
how can we help
and let him opt out does that sound
right
that sounds great cool i would um
as cheesy as this sounds i'd probably
pre-game it with my buddies
i'd probably get two or three guys and
say hey we're gonna all go out and
more than that then it feels like an
intervention like one of those tv shows
um but two or three guys and i would
talk about it before you go um
hey i'm gonna do the talking or you do
the talking or let's set this up in this
way but
that way there's that's not all that
weird awkward and then there's always
one idiot that pops off with something
dumb
like oh you know whatever i struggle
with
it's not about y'all's struggles it's
about hey brother we see that you're
hurting
and how can we love you so i appreciate
your heart tony even though you
um don't know what makes a good guitar i
appreciate your heart and the world
needs more people like you who want to
lean into their
their friends lives and um love on them
a little bit better
and again man addiction's hard he may
explode he may start crying
he may say yell or stupid idiots and
just leave
understand that that's his choice to
make let him know that he's loved
never stop pursuing him but also don't
give him carte blanche to run all over
everything make sure you've got firm
boundaries there
right thank you for your heart brother
tony